>>Narrator: At this high school in a
suburb north of Chicago, the sights
and sounds of youngsters
having fun fill the halls.
>>Student: Are you ready?
Okay, go, shake, shake, shake.
>>Narrator: In this unique
program, high school students learn
about early childhood development
by teaching lessons for little ones.
>>Student: So let's all count how
many stuffed animals we've got, okay?
So throw yours in first,
and that's one, two, three--
>>Karen: This is one of
our large motor activities.
It's an opportunity for
listening and following directions
for the children, but also just
moving your body, because you know,
we need to move our body
a lot during the day.
We get a little wiggly.
>>Narrator: The Deer Park Teaching
And Learning Center was launched
in 1992, when Deerfield High
teachers urged the school
to provide child care
for their children.
The center now offers seven
child development classes
for high school students, with child
care tuition covering the salaries
of the child development class
teachers, and staff at the center.
>>Karen: We are really
a full time lab school
for the child development students.
It's a great experience for
our children, because they get
to have more one-on-one time
with their high school
friends, as they call them.
>>Student: What color is that?
Yellow?
>>Karen: It's also a great experience
for the high school students,
because they get to try on a
career, apply some of these skills,
either at a part time job
babysitting, working at a camp.
It's also a great experience
for them to say, wow,
children are a huge responsibility
that maybe I'm not quite
ready for right now.
>>Student: Do you want to go there?
I'll go, like that.
>>Karen: But, for the most part, we
do have a lot of high school students
that get started in our program,
just as an elective class,
and find their path, saying, I
really would like to be a teacher.
>>Child: Oh no, look.
>>Jenn: We're taking observations
on how the kids develop over time.
We write down how they interact with
each other, their large motor skills,
their small motor skills, and
their intellectual development.
>>Narrator: Child development
classes meet four days each week.
>>That's good, okay.
>>Narrator: Students spend one day
studying child development theory,
and three periods each week, getting
hands on experience by planning,
observing and teaching lessons.
>>Student: We could
like, make fireworks
and have a little bouncy
balls and shake
around bouncy balls or something.
>>Student: Okay, what
colors do you want to use?
>>Student: Bright colors.
>>Jenn: I love this class, because
I want to be a preschool teacher
when I'm older, so it's really
great to learn all this now, like,
being this young, get to work hands
on with them, because you really get
to see if it's something
you want to work with.
>>Good night nobody, good night mush.
>>Karen: I think everybody gets
to benefit, whether it's teachers
in the high school, who get to come
to work with their child every day,
get to stop in at lunchtime,
it's a great benefit for them,
teaching in the building.
It's a great experience for the
high school student, to have a class
where they get to be actively
involved, a lab experience.
It's also wonderful
for our preschoolers--
>>Jenn: So who liked the old
lady with Spring Hush, the best?
>>Karen: Really, it is a
program that anybody could do,
and what a wonderful
experience for everybody.
Everybody wins.
>>Student: Keep turning.
What are they doing?
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.